[Musique]
à mi temps qui vous diront qu'ils
traitent de la vie si tu kankan est
astucieux belle
johnny le plus sérieux que ça me va vite
à jouer aujourd'hui il suffit de vouloir
devenir amis
qu'est-ce que tu es ce que tu essayes de
faire avec ce bateau tu essaies i sava
ina elika cv nous effrayer non mais ça
va être difficile
ça va être difficile parce que nous
allons tenter une expérience aujourd'hui
en disant bonjour à tous nos amis oui
ont l'expérience extrêmement délicate et
je ne saurais trop vous conseiller de la
faire avec l'aide de vos parents parce
que ça peut présenter tout de même
quelques inconvénients et vous allez
comprendre tout de suite pourquoi tu me
suit ou encore regarde où va-t-on et
bats toi tu restes là mais tu vas voir
ce que je vais faire et touati tout tu
regardes
oui très bien alors voilà comment les
choses ans pas si je vais à l'aide de ce
bâton superbe tenter de briser ce bois
entre les deux verres remplis d'eau que
voici
et tout le style consiste à ne pas
renverser les verts et vous ça c'est
extrêmement délicat en donnant un énorme
coup de bâton au milieu tout le monde
est prêt et dis attention
et voilà ben c'était c'était juste un
enfin on a tout de même réussi au petit
il a eu peur tu y trouves qui tout est
complètement tremblotant on va pauvre
petit oulalala sa garde à vue avoir fait
peur mon beauf aux poursuites ou pauvres
qui dit tout va mieux tout ou week avait
bon alors je vais au mot-à-mot hockey a
tout de suite a certes un sacré travail
qui dans quel travail
bon vous avez vu le bateau et les gros
1,6 de l'open du parti tout comme ça en
bas non ça va mieux
fabrice oui oui et je t'écoute le
district de spin boldak
oui oui oui le jour notamment les
enfants jouent au motown avril soit
après du nom à avait ça m'a fait peur
moi aussi je vais mettre mon bâton
là-bas basque
- voilà alors cinq cartes deux cartons 3
4 et 5
voilà un art ça c'est un oiseau dont je
suis jaloux à 3 il est beau un très beau
4 et 5
alors tous qu'encore et ben oui ce
premier c'est le pan le port rêvait
d'être un pont tandis les jeux et là ça
c'est la rose et la rose et la sas et
impôts à riom ah oui
ah qu'est ce que c'est que ça c'était
l'alcool koné et c'est un assaut lâche
alors vous essayez de faire des mots
avec ça on l'a la banda lous seront en
plomb des rampes ou non bon cole non les
bus roulent à 6 d'ici la mi journée
mais j'avoue j'ai eu cours au hip hop
comme un groupe à un coup de bol ah oui
mais alors tu pars tu prends ça comme un
coût alors il faut le dire alors mes
enfants alors qu'au pôle pense à toi oui
oui mais alors moi je ne le savais pas
mais là j'ai déjà intégré les coupons
tous pourris c'est pas mal c'est pas un
coupon mais alors malgré des émotions
c'est quand même fort à leurs coupons
oui après tout oui c'est bien c'est bien
une femme
bon il faut ressortir des cartes parce
que c'est là et ça c'est quoi
ah ça c'est ainsi fabrice oui c'est un
joker à 7 ha en place on peut faire ce
qu'on veut
ah bon c'est alors qu'elle le gallois
lab avec sa conscience et lass n'importe
quelle carte
ça y est moi j'en ai un coire ben
justement avec le n o ben oui en asie
alors tu sors lan a win and and dans tu
sors le joker oui anne encore en cavale
avait man and woman annabaoui à nana
mais hormis d'axway
alors ça c'est que je n'avais pas le
courage au caire obama j'aurais trouvé
tout de suite à la la ah oui c'est très
bien c'est bien joué
bojana et ben mes enfants m'ont bravo
vous avez bien travaillé
nous allons revoir ensemble un petit peu
notre courrier car on aimerait que nos
amis nous envoie énormément de jolies
lettres beaucoup de très jolis être avec
de très très beaux dessins je vous en
remercie au nom des petits camarades
alors celle que nous avons sélectionné
cette semaine guy duhaime qui cousin qui
a envoyé et puis c'est jamais arrivé
avant alors déchire tout cas oui mais
via les allées de christophe coutry qui
habite argenteuil et il a 6 ans
christophe alors regardez regardez ça si
c'est pourquoi vous avez mois sera la
fin un paysage et nous perdons avec je
trouve qu'il ya de belles perspectives
le soleil en eau les nuages ça c'est
très bien faire oui ça te plaît tout
concourt ce vélo si oui alors nous
allons récompenser
oui en lui envoyant le disque des quatre
amis voilà bon et ben chan ça va être à
nous oui j'espère que tu n'as pas encore
oublié ton moqueur regarde alors nous a
fait peur telle heure oui alors c'est un
mot en neuf lettres
oui et c'est quoi la première c'est un m
voilà oui alors les petits traits comme
d'habitude alors 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 et arles
la dernière indé comme denise des bons
alors en ce moment comme toujours
gourmand oui je suis sur sa semence et
oui oui je mange tout le temps sera venu
parce que j'ai j'ai toujours faim
comment je m'en suis comme toi et c'est
un dessert et en mon nom c'est pas nous
certains de ces points d'essai c'est
cette instance est un hors d'oeuvre et
nous renouons non plus non plus j'ai pas
la vie en garderait c'est de la viande
non non j'ai pas de la viande qu'on
donnera dans ses prévisions alors écoute
écoute écoute est ce que tu veux une
petite led peut-être le meneur litres
est alors la troisième oui
la troisième c'est un c'est à la ligue 1
c à c est ainsi bon alors c'est pas de
la viande s'est pas fait est ce que ce
sont des pâtes ses sauts des pâtes tous
adorent lit pas bon c'est bon vraiment
l'ennui vois tu sais que là encore
j'entends bien peur ah bon tu nous ait
fait une faute d'orthographe sont
monstrueuses important j'étais sûre de
moi tu penses à macaronis macaronis
alors voilà caroni mamacounda maccarone
hausse écrit comme ça
incapable au mais ça n'arrête pas
décidément jamais tu n'as prendre à
l'orthographe
comment comme à cannes
elle y voit là un mac un gars pas de d
enfin y'a pas de temps cabanes d'oiseaux
moi j'écris macaronis parce que pour moi
les macaronis gamme qui trouve au milieu
alors ça ça fait comme un nid d'oiseau
alors moi j'ai écrit un idée qu'est ce
que tu veux c'est pas de ma faute
pourtant j'étudie toute la semaine
j'étudie puis tu vois vrai le résultat
enfin enfin se consoler on va les
emmener avec moi c'est pas si la musique
tu verras à la parade de vanins samassa
[Musique]
520 ha ben aujourd'hui figure toi
fabrice que je vais te demander de
reconnaître un instrument que j'adore
ah ah oui quel instrument avait pas de
lui dit tu vas me lebihan non non je le
fais écouter bord alizée puis sur le
bouton de ma petite boîte
[Musique]
alors oui alors écoute c'est
certainement un saxophone
oui mais tout le problème et savoir de
quelle saxophone il s'agit car c'est une
grande famille vous savez c'est comme
les cordes il y a beaucoup de saxophones
différents savez le très gros d'un
saxophone baryton faut être très solide
pour les porter il va le saxophone c'est
le grand père si tu veux mais le
saxophone ténor qui est déjà un peu plus
petit et en finir tout de même important
le saxophone alto que l'on utilise
beaucoup en musique classique et je
pense que c'est celui que nous avons
entendu c'est celui qui nous avons
entendu je crois oui et puis alors il ya
le saxophone soprano qui comme une
clarinette tout droit comme ça il ya
encore quelques autres saxophone des
tout-petits perd beaucoup plus gros mais
on les utilise vraiment très très peu ça
sont les principaux ça doit être un
saxophone alto nous qui lui là bas je
pense oui je crois que j'ai fait le tour
de la famille des saxophones à moi que
j'en oubliais même semble que non
baryton le ténor l'alcool soprano sont
les plus utilisés en tous les cas
oui mais tu sais comme moi je jouait du
saxophone ténor dans un orchestre
d'étudiants 6 6 passes mais ici mais si
tu tiens je vais aller le chercher tu
vas voir à we are very chercher mon
saxophone un regard si les mains à il
est chic intuition comme je suis oui bah
je sais pas on va voir un petit peu
voire faut mettre un collier parce que
son des instruments que sont un petit
peu un petit peu lourd à porter alors
vous imaginez le baryton qui est énorme
il faut être très costaud et plus alors
celui là c'est le saxophone ténor
bon alors on va essayer on veut
l'embaucher
voir je vais mettre là à cul tu tombes
al kheir oui mais j'en ai pas besoin
maintenant mal d'accord à allah faut
oublier un petit peu parce que il ya une
hanche qui vibre c'est un petit morceau
de bois je ne sais pas si vous pouvez la
voir là en gros plan voyez vous c'est
une petites lamelles de bois qui vibre
et c'est cette vibration qui donne le
sont à voir alors quatre corps
et voilà ça sonne bien fondé
kovacs à 8h et très bien je souffle mois
doucement vas-y attend ben alors alalala
sa fin quand ça se fait qu'il vient rien
dit et c'est à toi bell bell ça m'a un
petit peu la belle belle taille et bien
à leur souffle alors rien à faire là bas
c'est difficile c'est difficile
vous voilà pourquoi ce qu'il faut faire
on essaiera la prochaine fois parce que
vous avez manqué de souffle un tous les
deux roues jaloux fautes et nous allons
chanter allez qui l'amène au saxophone
et aux chambres
les quatre amis c'est déjà ça elle a mis
le calme environ mille secrets que la
vie majeur est désisté et g shock 2 des
choses pour les comme juni patinoire
niveau à faire attention que les cas de
familles sont 34 ans rudy meilhac
ça me sens heureux car il aime la vie
oui
[Musique]
les gagnants qui vous invite à jouer
aujourd'hui il suffit de vouloir devenir
un ami il suffit de vouloir devenir ali
tient tout couac on le sait bien les
seuils plus encore regarde là
[Musique]